this new book, The Infinite Game is exactly
the same. It's me on my journey which is
the same journey that we're all on.
Which is I'm living in the world I'm
functioning in the world I'm an idealist
I talk about the world I want to live in
and quite frankly I got tired of people
in power, people who run companies,
people who work on Wall Street telling me then
I'm naive I'm stupid
and I don't understand how business works and when I
discovered this little book called
Finite and Infinite Games by James Carse that was written in 1986, it gave me
a whole new perspective on how the world
actually works that we are at all
moments of all days players in games
that have no finish lines.
There's no such thing as winning friendship. There's
no such thing as winning in marriage if
you think you're going to be number one
in your marriage it's not gonna go well
and there's definitely no such thing as
winning business and yet you listen to
so many leaders and they talk about
being number one, being the best,
beating their competition. They have no idea how the world is actually working
they're playing with the wrong mindset
for the game that they're actually
playing and when you play with a finite
mindset in an infinite game you damage
trust, you damage cooperation, and you
hurt innovation and eventually the
organization struggles and goes into
decline. For me this little idea the
reason I wanted to write about it is
this is a world as flat moment all that
discomfort that so many of us have at
work and we're told by out by the powers
that be and those that work in
finance that we're the naive ones
yet we're still uncomfortable with the way
these things are going. This is the world
is flat moment as I said. It turns out
that they don't understand how business
works and we're on to something and I
wrote this book for two reasons
it wasn't to convince or convert anybody it
was a rallying cry to anyone who thinks
that the way that we're conducting
business these days the kind of form of
capitalism that we've built that there's
something wrong with it
I can't quite put my
finger on it but it feels uncomfortable
and it was also to show us what
finite mindedness looks like so we
can recognize finite minded companies
and finite minded leaders so we can
avoid working for them.
This is like a little manifesto
of the world that could be and I hope
it's one more step to advancing to this
world in which we can wake up inspired
feel safe and return home fulfilled.
I'm so grateful to all of you
who are in this business.
We are compatriots in this movement and thank
you so so much
for helping me spread these ideas
because together we're
making a difference
we really are making a difference.
Thank you very much